so today we're going to look at the
classic puzzle it's called the eight
Queens puzzle and very easy to describe
I'll write down the rules if you happen
not to know chess and how a queen moves
on a chess board in a moment but before
I get into that I just wanted to mention
that the programming paradigms that
we're going to be looking at today are
is is I should say the programming
paradigm is is one of exhaustive
enumeration and the what we want to do
algorithmically is to look at all
possible cases all possible combinations
possibilities because we want to exhaust
the space to determine if there's a
solution to this particular instance of
the problem or not and one of the
problems as I mentioned is the 8 Queens
problem but you can imagine that you
could say I'd like to solve a smaller
problem the five Queens problem of the
three Queens problem and you'd like
obviously to be able to write code that
solves this generalized problem where
you can vary the number of rows and
columns on a board and it's no longer a
chess board if it's not a dros and eight
columns but you can still obviously
concoct a puzzle associated with an
arbitrary size boat and then the other
thing we that we'll do today is look at
data structures and so this obviously
are going to be a data structure that's
immediately clear from what I have up
there on the board
matrix data structure to solve the
problem but can you do things more
efficiently with the different selection
of a data structure all right so the 8
Queens problem is it simply says like
place
eight queens on a chessboard and that
implies immediately that it's 8x8 as
I've drawn over there such that no Queen
attacks any other cream now if you had
no background in solving this problem
perhaps you knew chess and you might
think there's a solution you might think
there's not I mean a queen is pretty
powerful
a queen I this implies because the Queen
can move horizontally can move
vertically and can move diagonally in a
back-and-forth in in both directions up
and down left and right and I guess up
and down diagonally I it's it's it's a
powerful piece it's the most powerful
piece in chess and how can you in first
time I heard about this problem I my
guess was that there wasn't a solution
today Queen's problem right and you know
how many of you think there's a solution
to this problem right do you know
there's a solution how do you think this
a solution
so so he cannot process dissolution how
many of you before you you heard him
thought there wasn't the solution right
well you know years ago I was convinced
that there was no solution because I
tried very hard and I couldn't find one
I tried very hard for a half hour okay
and and then I decided there wasn't one
right so but but then you know we can
you could now at this point I or it got
to the point where I could write a
computer program in in about a half hour
or an hour to solve this problem and I
did discover a solution so I'm kind of
giving it away it turns out there's many
solutions and at there's certainly
different code for slightly different
code for finding one solution versus
finding all of them right and will do
both so without further ado that you
want to translate the movement of the
Queens into a set of rules that tell you
if you found the solution or not and
there's basic there's essentially three
rules because the Queen can move in
three different ways
no two queens can be on the same column
no two queens can be in the same row
no two queens can be in the same
diagonal and remember there's two
diagonals one of which that goes this
way another one that goes that way
right so there's a lot of combinations
here if you think about this and you
look at this board over here I have
eight different I rose and eight
different columns and the way that
someone might try to solve this problem
is go
you know either left to right or top
down and I've written the constraint no
two queens can be in the same column
first so you can imagine and this is
what we're going to do I you could
certainly modify the code and modify our
strategy but we're going to go left to
right so what we're going to do is we
know we put a queen up here we can't put
a queen in any other row on that first
column obviously because of the first
constraint so maybe I'll put a queen up
here and then at that point I can move
to the second column in my manual
strategy and I could put a queen up up
here because of the second constraint no
two queens can be in the same row if I
had a queen up here let me just write
that up so I can't put one here I can't
put one here I could put one here and
this goes back to what ganado said about
this is how a knight moves in chess and
so so that gets me to Queens and
obviously not a solution to the problem
of the eight Queens but maybe I'm a
quarter of the way there right and it
turns out if you have to do what is
called backtracking and backtracking
simply means you may have to undo a
decision you made with respect to the
placement of a particular Queen in this
exhaustive search strategy right and the
important thing when you when you do
search as I mentioned early on you have
to convince yourself that the code
you've written is going to exhaust all
of the possibilities and that it won't
miss solutions and if you don't exhaust
all the possibilities your code will
terminate
and you may throw up your hands because
you had buggy code or because you had a
buggy a search strategy and say there's
no solution to the problem but as there
is a solution to the problem
all right so and and the way you do this
search this exhaustive search because
it's quite intense there's a lot of
combinations and they grow exponentially
with the number of rows and columns in
on our board is important um and so you
want to be careful that you don't do
redundant work that you don't do things
that you don't really have to because
the combinations you know blow up
so there's hundreds of millions of
combinations with respect to putting
queens up here so if you really think
about it there's like a difference of
places you can put a queen here eight
eight eight etc so you know there's a
trace to eight right if you if you think
about that and that's a large number
right and if you translate that I don't
even know what that is but it's you
could do you know this is to raise to 3
raise to 8 so that's 2 raise to 24 which
which is in the in the millions and if
you had a larger if you had a larger
board
it was isn't a chess board then it would
be much much larger right as you as you
grew the size of the board but that to
raise to 24 doesn't scare us these days
because computers are so fast but back
when I was your age that was a large
number ok and you didn't want to write
code that took to raise to 24 steps to
solve problems now it takes a matter of
fractions of seconds do to run through
those kinds of combinations because
you're running at a gigahertz on
computers but before we dive into the
specifics of a particular strategy let's
look at smaller problems
you always get intuition about about
problems by shrinking them and making
them simpler so let's look at the case
of a 2x2 board can I solve the 2 Queens
problem on a two-by-two board no right
so if I put a queen here
immediately I cannot put a cream it
attacks all of these other positions the
2x2 does not have a solution let's look
at 3x3 right so let's say I put a queen
up here so the way I'm doing this by the
way is column by column and that's kind
of going to be our strategy as I said
you could flip it to row by row but I no
reason to do both just pick one and so I
put a queen up here I can't put one here
I can't put one here I can't put one
here right so I go ahead and put that
over here can I put a queen here no
because that attacks it can I pretty
Queen here no because this attacks it
and clearly I can't build over here so
so am I done
I can I just give up now what should I
do
alright I don't want to give up now I
don't want to say that at three by three
at this point I don't know what the
answer is in terms of whether a solution
exists for a 3x3 or not but but at this
point I given that I put a queen up here
and I went through this process I I
cannot give up right and why Cannot I
give up what should I do next once I've
failed here I put a queen here the Queen
here and I said you know I can't put a
queen anywhere here what do I do
right yeah go ahead Fadi
of the first queen that's exactly right
so I need to backtrack so I tried a few
different things here and it was exactly
the same thing where I had a queen here
and let's say I have a very
straightforward strategy that's that is
going to put Queens down and run a piece
of code that is going to check for
conflicts this is this is going to be
our most important subroutine that we're
going to write and it's going to be
dependent on the data structure that we
pick but that is our our fundamental
check you know the conflict checker so I
could put a queen here and obviously
with one queen there's no reason to run
the conflict checker then I put a queen
here
I run the conflict checker and it says
conflict here conflict here no conflict
right and then I move on to the next and
I get conflict for all three of them
right so at this point I have to have a
way in my code this is exactly the
enumeration that I need in my code to go
back and say just like I tried different
combinations for the second column
before I converged on putting a clean
down here I need to go back and change
this to do this so I put a queen here
then can I put a queen here here here no
right so that doesn't work either so
then I go up and put a queen here and
now you know where this is headed
because of symmetry I can only place I
can put a queen is over here and once I
put a queen over there I can't put a
queen in any of these spots right so it
turns out a three by three does not have
a solution at this point because I've
gone through all of the combinations
with respect to the starting points on
the first column and and then with each
of those starting points I've gone
through all of the combinations in the
second column and that and the third
column I've effectively done the tree
raised to 3 which was basically what I
described to you previously with respect
to these different combinations now I I
don't know if the aide we kind of think
at this point that there is
a solution in those eight rates to eight
combinations for the 8 Queens problem
but there's no solution in the to raise
to 2 combinations for the 3 Queens for
the 2 Queens problem and there were no
solutions in the 3 raise to 3
combinations or placements for the 3
Queens problem okay
so let's do 4 Queens and the reason I'm
doing this is I want to point out one
thing which is an efficiency a trick
that is gonna be important to make sure
that our code runs in a reasonable
amount of time right and which is kind
of implicit in what we have done here
but I want to point it out all right so
in the in the case of 4 Queens I'm gonna
go off and I'm gonna put queen up here
and I'm gonna run through this fairly
quickly no no yes
and so I move on no no no no no right so
so oops but now I don't need to go back
all the way to the first I can I can put
a queen here right so now no yes so I
get a little further and then I can move
to the fourth column no no no no I mean
they attack from here or attack from
there oops all right let's just go can I
put it over here no no I went back to
the most recently placed Queen okay so
so one thing that is important which you
kind of get a sense for when you
increase the size of the board is when
you fail when conflict check conflicts
returns false when you fail you go back
to the most recent decision most recent
column that you've placed your your your
queen and you change that and you
enumerate those possibilities okay and
and when you do that the other thing
that we've done by the way is when we
put after for the first Queen you know
we put a queen down with impunity for
the second Queen we checked the loan
existing Queen on the board at for a
conflict right for the third queen
and what am I doing here for the third
Queen I what conflicts am i checking
when I place the third Queen on one of
the rows of the third column
specifically what what conflicts am i
checking
I mean who am i checking with yeah go
ahead back there yeah to Queens and what
am i doing for the existing Queens that
are already on the board do i do I do
anything for them
No so that is I guess it doesn't seem
like much but it's an important notion
ok the notion here is I'm doing a
certain amount of incremental checking
when I place a new queen and it's only
the new relationships that the new queen
or the conflicts that the new queen
would have that need to be checked and
in general you know if I had seven
Queens up on the board and I've sort of
set it up nicely with these seven Queens
they're all happy right that they're
non-conflicting and no reason to go look
at each of those pairs of seven Queens
when I put an eighth Queen down as I
change the position of the eighth Queen
all I care about is that the eighth
queen doesn't conflict with the first
seven Queens so I have to check in
general if I'm putting the Kate Queen
down I'm effectively checking for four K
minus one pairs of conflicts or you know
K minus one Queens were already put down
the Kate queen is putting is been put
down and I need to check for the remain
for the ones that already existed I
don't have to do K minus one square
right you know because the K minus one
we're in there
they clearly have there's different
pairs over there I'm all done with that
all right I'm all done with that right
so so let's keep going here so what
where was I I forget exactly where was
that but we decided that this didn't
work because I failed on column four but
I can't put it over here and I can't put
it over here right so now at this point
I I've gone through and I've said look
for these two what means now is that for
these two positions of the four the
first two columns there's no solution to
the Four Queens
okay and so and and I so and I did I
exhausted the positions for this
position
I've also exhausted so I can say
something even stronger than that
because for this position I looked at
the two two possibilities which were
this and that and neither of them work
as well right so the stronger statement
now is that there's no solution to the
Four Queens problem if you put a queen
on the top left corner all right
but it doesn't mean that there's no
solution to the Four Queens problem I
can answer your question yes wonderful
so it turns out that you can do
rotations and reflections and if you are
willing to I to take your code remember
that computers are dumb you have to
explain to them what a rotation is and
what a reflection is but if you do that
then it turns out you can get
significant reductions in a trace to
eight or what have you
right and I'll I'll go back and I'll
tell you about the number of solutions
to the 8 Queens problem if you just
looked at it this way you know without
sort of you know rotating yourself or
reflecting and then and then tell you
how many unique solutions they actually
are if you took into account the
symmetries associated with rotation and
reflection and the the last part is
important because it can cut down your
comment Oriole search if you do take
that into account right but as I said
you know for our purposes to raise to 24
is not a large number anymore
so we can just blast through and not
have to do that
all right but now what I need to do is
I've erased everything you know I tried
that first queen in the corner it's
probably not going to work here right
and so because of I've been not probably
it will not work here sorry about that
but you know this is different right I
mean that clearly we have to check right
so so here no here no here no yes right
and then here yes right so I can put
that over here and then I move on here
no here no here
yes that's right so we don't know if
there's not another solution and in fact
there is there's two solutions everyone
go to that we won't go there but 4x4 I
I'm sorry for Queens has a solution okay
um so now we're ready to code okay now
we're ready to code um the one thing we
need to do is decide on a data structure
but before I show you the code or even
talk about the data structure I do want
you to keep in mind this search strategy
that we employed right and the search
strategy was a column by column search
strategy and it requires enumeration and
changing positions of Queens and
deciding when to do that is going to be
based on whether check conflicts gives
you back true or false and we can set up
check conflicts so it's not checking
this there's two ways you could do this
you could say here's a board I'm gonna
check all pairs of conflicts associated
with all the Queens on the board and I'm
gonna just use that procedure over and
over that's not what we did in our
search strategy what we did was we have
a check conflict strategy that really
takes a new queen as an argument and
sort of the existing a board as a second
argument right and it's it's really
checking for the new Queens conflicts
with the existing Queens and that cuts
down on the amount of computation that
you want to do all right so so given
that what is the most natural data
structure that you can think of that
would that would be applicable to the 8
Queens problem or the 4 Queens problem
what's the most natural data structure
that you can think of someone yeah go
ahead
2-dimensional array two dimensional list
what I have
Mirai so so let's say that I I decided
to do exactly what Brian suggested and
what I'm gonna do is I'm gonna have a
two dimensional array a two dimensional
list in a Python and it would call them
list which looks like this and this is
going to look exactly like the board
that you have there two dimensional this
is the the list of lists and you have
lists in here and so the important thing
people all of you if you haven't already
will spend some debugging time you know
in your programming careers figuring out
why things don't work trying to figure
out why things don't work and it'll be
because you flipped the I and J indices
of a two-dimensional array or a list
okay because you'll think that some
things are rose and some things are
columns and you'll flip them around so I
don't want to do that I already did that
you know enough times in my life so I
don't want to do that and so right here
I think of b0 as being the the b0 is the
first row right so this thing here is is
b0 so when I say something like B to 3
what is the value of B to 3 in my list
b1 and b3 2 is 0 ok so that's I mean I
could obviously have confused myself
there'll be a bug in the code if I
switch the the identities of rows and
columns right that's exactly the point
so I can now imagine that check
conflicts given
what we said about incremental checking
but it still has to do obviously
computation on the the be array or look
at the B array and decide what's going
on I'm gonna be putting in once and
zeros inside of the D array and the
first two I mean they're all
straightforward I mean this this it's
not complicated code here but but the
first two checks are slightly easier
than the third check no two queens on
the same column implies that I need to
actually look at the first index
changing you know from 0 to 3 and for
some particular what I just write this
out here so no two queens are the same
column would mean that I want to go 0
through let's just call it 7 because I
have the 8 Queens problem and then I
need to look at I where I varies
actually let me just call it a call that
J I like I for rows and J for columns
and J varies J would be 0 and you check
that B 0 7 0 only has 1 1 all right
that's essentially what I need to check
for and then i need to check it for J
equals 0 I need to check it for J equals
1 I need to check it for J equals 2 etc
right that makes sense
and then no two queens on the same row I
need to check that be I and I can go
from 0 to 7 I for I'm sorry no two
queens can be on the same row
yeah that's right so so I add this
couldn't this goes from 0 to 7 and then
I fixed the value of the column and no I
did this is fixed
so right now let's just say that I'd
look at the first row I'd go zero here
and then I go zero through seven here
and and then I make sure that on b0
there's exactly one one right all right
so we're all good here yeah okay well
the diagonal is the I and J both change
all right and the thing with the
diagonals and I'll show you the code for
this I think it's a it's much easier to
explain the code is supposed to drawing
things now because it's it's about the
specifics of things and so here here it
is right so what I have here is such I
called it no conflicts no conflicts has
at the board a [ __ ] are B array here
or B list in general we've been going to
be working incrementally on the current
column so that's what that is so you
move from 0 to all the way down and then
you have something that we're gonna call
Q index which is which is where you are
so you have to two things that we need
to worry about and you're working on up
on a column that's current and then you
also have the position that corresponds
to the corresponds to the row where
you're putting the Queen down so you
obviously need two of these values for
four to two point into the two
dimensional list so that's your cue
index over here and this simply is
setting n to be 4
I mean I could this is a general
procedure but because I'm calling this
in a for queens procedure are we gonna
do things iteratively now so I need to
know exactly how many rows and columns
they are on my board so I've just set
that up to be to be N equals 4 but
that's essentially the dimension so as
you can see the I'm gonna check that
this is a single one in the current
column um this is what I was trying to
go over over there but I think this code
is probably more evocative
I'm simply checking to see that the
number of ones in the current column is
not greater than one if it's greater
than one then immediately I'd return
false
and and then here this is a little bit
easier I checked that the the current
Queen is the Moreau on which the current
Queen is on only has one Queen on it and
for for the remember as I'm going
there's a single one in the current in
the current column and this thing here
says I need to check that when I put a
queen down here that this is the I need
to check out this entire road to make
sure that this Queen is the only one on
it right and then I also need to check
this and that okay and so those two
checks are over here this and that so
the diagonal the left diagonal is the
first one the first check and then the
one that goes over to the right is the
second check right and again yeah
[Music]
as we progress
that's a great question so I'm gonna I'm
gonna answer that in a minute or so
all right so so he thought he was asking
about whether the checks are redundant
or not I mean he and and he was pointing
to a particular piece of code let me
explain this code and then I'll answer
for this question okay so what I have
here is is our this is actually the the
search algorithm right and this is
exactly what we've talked about up until
this point you you're going to go over
you want to go column by column right
and then you're going to go row by row
and so that's essentially what what the
two loops are there's lots of loops here
obviously right you know this is this
horrible code right I mean I'm not
saying this is this is pretty code right
but this is horrible code and and what
happens here is over here I'm going to
go ahead and say this is I'm starting
with I'm gonna vary I'm starting with
the first column so the column is fixed
here okay remember I'm going column by
column so that's why this is a zero and
then I'm going to vary the position of
the Queen on the row okay and that I
varies alright and then the next thing
I'm gonna do is I'm going to go to the
second column and I'm going to that so
that's why this is a 1 and then I'm
going to vary the position of the Queen
on the on each of the rows corresponding
to the second column and so on and so
forth right that's it right it's a
brutal code ok and I'll show you I've
wrote code for eight Queens it goes all
the way to there right but so that's it
I mean you know you can see it's simple
code I'm not you know sometimes you know
brutish means simple not always and so
there's no conflicts thing is is is
essentially something that that is
calling this a the this no conflicts
procedure that is doing all of the
things that I just described to you
right and so if I go ahead and run this
and run this with four Queens
oh yeah it's this always happens after a
while it's going to come back but when I
run this with with with with four Queens
let me see if this is going to run one
more time
ah sorry I've been fighting this system
bug ever since I installed mac OS Sierra
on my laptop there you go
so so this this gave me at my two
solutions one of which is up there on
the board and there's the second
solution for the for Queens problem
alright so let me go back to to answer
for this question right so so the idea
here and the way I described this was
look I as I go column by column I only
put one queen down on this particular
column the current column that I'm
working on and the way I have this code
set up
notice that I'm setting setting this
this to be one and then I'm resetting it
down below here the gi0 whether it's I
there's this line of code and this line
of code there are paired together or
this line of code in this line of code
these two things are ensuring that
there's exactly one queen on any given
column because I'm only putting that
Queen down and then I'm taking it out
and putting it in another spot right so
and that's how I describe this entire
procedure to you manually right and
that's how we work through it so so your
contention body is that this check is
redundant right and you're right right
you're absolutely right
and so if I comment out that check
everything works exactly it's a little
bit faster but everything works exactly
the same all right so it was the reason
I put the check in there you asked the
question I was going to you ask you the
question so but but it's a good question
right so so that's kind of the summary
of for Queens you can clearly imagine
generalizing this to the two eight
Queens it looks even more ugly this is
what that looks like and in fact it
would look worse except I decided that
I'd employ the continue statement right
so I don't know how many of you know
of the continuous statement but the the
continues statement essentially says if
there's an F a predicate followed by
continue and the predicate is true then
you immediately start the next iteration
of the loop okay so there's two ways
that you could you could say I don't
want to do anything for the rest of the
loop right this there's two ways you
could do this one is you could say so I
have a for loop here dot dot and and if
I say if condition then you you you you
do do stuff right and so this do is
indented inside of the if compare that
with for if not condition continue and
here you'd have do stuff the same do
stuff right now if this do stuff has
indentations in it then you're better
off I mean just because I have so many
indentations you're better off doing
this strategy right because if do stuff
you know goes on and has a bunch of ifs
in it then you at least started at this
level as opposed to starting at this
level which is too deep right so that's
absolutely the only reason why I used to
continue over here because it would look
even more ugly if I hadn't used continue
all right
so if you run this and and and the only
other thing I'm gonna get back to no
conflicts in a second but we'd go ahead
and run this and you see that there's 92
different solutions to the 8 Queens
problem if you don't take into account
rotations and reflections okay
and all of those solutions are being
printed out and so then the question is
you know what does that mean right what
is that what does that mean and that
comes to our selection of the day of the
data structure all right so we did this
this was the this was the data structure
that
you you would you you picked which is
the natural data structure you can
imagine that you could do something that
is more compact much more compact and I
want to show you how you could optimize
this code both for succinctness as well
as memory efficiency by picking a
different data structure right so let's
exploit the fact that each column has
only one Queen allowed right so we want
to exploit the fact that each column
only has one Queen allowed right so if
you think about it and you say well I
have this big thing here but each of the
columns has exactly one Queen and sure I
could use a bit like I did before of 0 &
1 to specify it but I do know that you
know this thing is going to be all zeros
1 and then a 1 followed by all zeros or
1 followed by all zeros etc etc right so
it's really constrained if I look at
that first column as to what the value
of that column is right and so I kind of
gave it away by running this but what
could I do now with respect to
representing the configuration of the
board by doing some amount of compaction
right what can I do those of you look at
look at the screen and yeah go ahead
I could just have a single a variable
that corresponds to the to the row
number that I that this particular queen
is on right in that column right and
that's exactly what's going on out there
all right so so if I just take that and
and I take I'll do the I'll do the the
bottom one because that's the easiest
for me to see but the the Rose goes 0
through 7 so what that says is that on
the first column I have a queen up here
okay and then at the third one I have a
queen so I have a queen here and 0 oh I
messed up thank you whoo that would have
been bad so 3 and then over here and
then what do I have to write so 2 is
over here I'm gonna have a panic attack
if if I end up getting a conflict I draw
these and put these queens up here you
know my name will be mud okay so 5 is
over here and then 1 is this one over
here right and 6 is out here and then
finally for is out here okay all right
don't tell me there's a conflict even if
there's one I refuse to refuse to admit
that all right so that's one of the
solutions to the to the 8 Queens problem
and as I mentioned this early 12
distinct ones and so so it turns out you
don't need to muck with a two
dimensional list which is confusing and
you start flipping eyes and J's and your
life is miserable right so let's just go
with a single dimensional list right
let's just say that if I had and
something like this and in fact I'm not
putting a queen down on this second
column this is not something we would do
in this algorithm but I just want to
show you generality right
I'm gonna take that and I'm going to
represent this as you can imagine as it
as a single dimensional Python list and
I'm just going to put what am I going to
put down here according to what I just
described to you I'm gonna put one and
what do you think I should put down here
should I put zero no no at the zero
would be bad right because that would
imply that there's a queen here I could
put minus one right - one could imply
that there's no queen on that column and
I could start with the board it is empty
which is all - once right and then this
one would be this is minus one yep sorry
I drew it once let me write this like
that minus 1 that's 1 and then I would
have two here and then 0 there ok so
what's cool about this is the the
overall a procedure in terms of the
column by column incremental checking
you know that a control flow of the
algorithm can stay the same I mean
individual for Queens it could the code
would would look slightly different
because obviously our board data
structure is a little bit different I'm
gonna show you the 8 Queens code in a
minute but it's effectively the same
algorithm right there's 8 loops for 8
Queens there's 4 loops for 4 Queens and
a little bit of bookkeeping with respect
to putting that the Queen on a column
would imply that I'm changing minus 1 to
0 or I'm changing 2 to 3 or something
like that as opposed to doing what I did
previously which was putting in a 1 for
a particular element in the two
dimensional list and then making it a 0
and then putting a 1 in a different spot
right so even that gets a little simpler
because I'm just overriding when I go 2
to 3 it means that I'm moving this Queen
from here to there ok so there's that
which is fairly minor what is much more
interesting is our check conflicts
procedure or no conflicts procedure and
what that would look like right and we
had a bunch of code some of it was
redundant for
for no conflicts but let's look at the
code for no conflicts in this case and
and that's it it's four lines of code
okay and this is not redundant right you
know so if you guys can make this code
smaller a plus right off the bat okay
well it is the pass/fail class but I'll
write you a letter okay so so this this
is essentially the the code that would
take this new data structure and check
conflicts in an incremental way okay
same thing you know I'm gonna add a new
queen to the mix and I'm gonna be
checking the conflicts of this new queen
versus the existing Queens all right and
so let's go through this because I have
some time and that's the last thing I
want to do so what I have here is it I'm
I'm not going to be checking anything
about the columns all right because I
know that the number is going to
basically the invariant here is there's
going to be some number here if it's a
negative number there's nothing on that
column and if there's a positive number
it better be between 0 and the number of
rows minus 1 and that is going to tell
me the where the one queen is right so
I'm done with that
so but the I highly do have to check
that there's there's a there's a row if
there's a real problem they could be a
real problem right so I could put I
could put a queen up here and obviously
I have to detect that correct so the way
I detect that is by the highlighted code
where I'm just going to check to see
whether there's two numbers that are
repeated corresponding to maccer --nt so
I know that what the value of current is
it's not going to be minus one because
current is going to be a real queen put
into a particular position I mean the
last thing you want is to check to minus
once and for equality and throw up a
conflict because I mean that's just
empty versus empty you know there's no
conflict but board current is is
guaranteed by the invocation procedure
to be a positive number or not I should
say non-negative number either a 0 up
until 7 in our case over a Queens
problem and I just need to check to see
that that value let's call it 4 doesn't
exist in in any of the other columns
correct so that's it it's it's a little
loop but it's real lines of code and in
that same loop we're going to be
actually checking for for 4 it turns out
both classes of diagonal conflicts okay
what that in this line of code here can
someone explain me explain to me what
this line of code is doing right what
what am I doing here I mean even
pictorially would be fine or you know
use your arms and wave right what what
is that line of code doing
I mean roughly it's it's checking for
diagonal conflicts but I want more right
how is it checking for diagonal
conflicts yeah
so if you think about what's going on
remember we're talking squares here you
know no rectangles right maybe we could
have a homework assignment where we have
rectangular chess boards and do things
and confuse everybody right but the good
news here is that it's the square right
I like squares okay and so and squares
are easy to deal with because you you
end up with in a situation where um you
know that how much you move in this
direction should be exactly the same
that you move in the other direction
all right that's what a diagonal in a
chessboard is right you know on a square
board is you need to move in the same
shape the same amount of movement right
so you're not talking about diagonals
that that look like that right that's
that's not what you're talking about
so what this means is if you go look at
this line of code what it says is I my
current is telling me for a for this
particular column I it's telling me what
row I'm on okay that's really what the
value that the the the the value I'm
sorry this is this is the the column
number excuse me I misspoke current is
telling me what the what the column
number is okay and
this board card board current is telling
me what what row number there is so
board current gives me the the row
number for the current column all right
and I is whatever a column that I'm
comparing against I need to enumerate
the different columns that I'm comparing
against all right so if I look at this
and that you'll find that the difference
between
this is this is one one at two one right
so this is this is this column is two
and and the row is one right so I just
say 2 equals column and row equals 1 for
this thing over here right and then I'll
use a different color for this one
here I have the column 3 the column is
equal to 3 and and the row equals zero
okay right um clearly that's a conflict
correct and and and the reason there's a
conflict mathematically speaking is
because the difference in the columns is
the same as the difference in the rows
okay
3 minus 2 about 2 - 3 - happens to be
greater than sorry - happens to be less
than 3 3 happens to be greater than 2
but the absolute value of the difference
is it's something that you need to take
into account because you could have
diagonals both in both directions right
so that ABS the absolute value over
there is key because it tells you that
it's checking for both this diagonal as
well as this diagonals right and so
that's it so if you think about this
being a square and you go look at the
comparisons between the values on the
rows and if that value the difference is
the same in absolute terms as the
difference in the columns you have a
conflict otherwise you don't have a
conflict all right because then you're
going off the diagonal is going away
through the board but the queen is not
on it right so I guess I did run it so I
won't run it again but I'll leave you
with the thought and we'll talk about
this next time is how in heck can we
make this code look prettier all right
and I we will go to look at from here on
out we'll be looking at a a programming
paradigm that's that's very powerful I
won't give it away you probably know
what it is but we'll talk about it the
first thing tomorrow that is that and
one of the things we will do will do a
different puzzle tomorrow as
but we'll take a look at the 8 Queens
code make it prettier and also I get it
to the point where it solves the N
Queens problem where n is an input to
the to the procedure the problem with
this code is it only solves 8 Queens I
showed you code for 4 Queens that only
solve for Queens if I told you that I
needed you to write code that solves n
Queens where n is an argument to the to
the procedure I you wouldn't be able to
do that with this iterative strategy
unless you bound it N and wrote in
different pieces of code right one of
which you know has four loops and the
other one has five loops and the other
one has six loops and you still need to
know what n is okay all right so see you
next time